I am happy to be here and to support you anyway that you need
I wanna try to share as much of my current life
so that you can see when you leave
it's amazing
but I do also try to still touch on the past to let you know like
I've been there and I know what you're going through
so whatever y'all need from me
that's what I'm here for
so I just love you guys
I support you
I'm here for you
I'm literally cheering you on
like this shit is
like is my life
my goal is just for as many women to be happy as they can
as many children to be as free as they can
like just for nobody to be feeling shitty and no shitty relationships
so I've been there
I know what it's like
I remember pretending and acting like everything was great and amazing
and it feels amazing to stop pretending
so I'm here for you I love you